in the hours and days following the
hurricane strike mobile phone apps can
not only be useful they can be downright
lifesavers from tracking the weather to
letting loved ones know that you're okay
the apps have been invaluable for those
in a storm's path here with more on how
the apps and cell phones can be
lifesavers is CNET senior editor Dan
Ackerman dan good morning hey guys I
feel like it was not that long ago we
were here talking about Zelo and the
importance of this aftering harvey what
is it why is it important that was one
that got very popular last year and it's
trendy again this year so it was like
the number three social app on the
iTunes App Store as of this morning it's
a push to talk style Voice app so
remember those old push-to-talk phones
where you communicate with somebody
walkie talkie style it does that over
the Internet so anywhere you have either
cell phone data or Wi-Fi connection you
can have instantaneous live real-time
chat with people gas is often a precious
commodity in natural disasters Dan is
there is there tech that can help you
with us well gas buddy is an app a lot
of people use for finding lowest prices
on gas and stuff they just turned on
their basically their storm tracker
slash hurricane tracker service which
tells you which gas stations are out of
gas and not only that which are out of
diesel which are out of regular and that
helped yes because there's no point in
driving to a gas station if there's
nobody there and they let you upload
your own info if you find a gas station
that's out of gas you can submit that so
you're floated out of your home a place
to stay you're looking for is there an
app for that I just talked to one called
harmony and it's sort of like a a crowd
sharing places to stay app it's like
Airbnb for disaster relief you can go on
and say I have a place to stay or I need
a place to stay and we'll match you up
with people and I like that they ask you
to do a lot of verification like upload
your ID and your phone number and verify
that you're a real person wasn't harm an
e with an A okay that's on the App Store
also the Red Cross has an app out there
but also directed at children explain
that I just started playing with this
last night if that was very cute it's
called monster guard and it's basically
a simple video game it's not gonna knock
kids socks off but once you get past
that it has a lot of useful interesting
stuff about hurricanes and other
disasters it tells you basically what to
do you have to walk through a house and
close all the windows if there's a
hurricane
gather your supplies I just started
working on the volcano tips when I came
in here we have to go back and finish
that one so now a lot of people are
probably saying you know what if my cell
phone battery's down and I can't use any
of this stuff you've actually got a
pretty valuable tip here this is
something I figured out during Hurricane
sandy many years ago when here in New
York I was in the blackout zone for days
I had some old laptops in my closet as
many pack rats do and I kept him charged
up it said there's a hurricane coming I
might lose power so I just kept him
plugged in don't use them anymore they
barely work when the power went out you
can use that it's a gigantic battery
it's got a you urging state on the side
plug your phone and you can get days of
phone charges full charges out of the
laptop so if you've been hoarding it and
not and not you know sending it off to
be recycled somewhere that that's a good
reason to keep those old laptops a great
use for those the Ackermann was just
some great tips thanks so much dad